from Auckland senior NBA rider from
ESPN's the undefeated always appreciate
our conversations with Marc Spears back
here on the show how are you mark
interesting a couple hours man I bet you
did
so is boogie done for the year yeah well
I don't know about for the year for the
season really tough news torn quad
waiting for the extent of the injury and
certainly has to be really really down
just the second playoff game and he's
out you know the Warriors win he still
gets a ring but he isn't a part of the
entire journey so I know he's crushed
Tony Parker had this injury recently so
I wouldn't be surprised if those two end
up having a conversation and Tony ended
up coming back but to go from having you
know the injury that cousins had and to
having this
I mean Achilles in a torn quad I mean it
is really devastating it's going to be
really painful and man I just after
seeing what he went through close to the
hand and been working on a biggie 60
feet Toronto for two years now amen if
they laughter he conquers this he
certainly has a very motivational story
hmm to say the least I mean just just to
hear again that he's been no doubt just
like the rest of the the Warriors that
this is the moment for him right now I
mean forget about obviously the last
couple of months it was all to get ready
for this moment and for this moment to
arrive and have it go like this it's
like an eye there's no words for it mark
yeah I mean hopefully he's box of
chocolate warriors kids find motivation
from this knowing how important just
getting in the playoffs was to him let
alone trying to win a championship
so hopefully for the Warriors sake they
could get sparks from it but his loss is
a huge loss assuming the Warriors figure
out a way to get past these Clippers
you know cousins was a problem for
Houston he had a great great series
against Houston he's a problem for a lot
of teams he's a lot problem for a lot of
star centers so to lose him I mean like
hey no one's gonna feel sorry for a team
four or five guys that have been
all-stars but this is a devastating loss
for the Warriors well before you get to
your other piece that you you wrote this
week for the undefeated on Kevin Durant
what in the world happened last night
mark I mean what what happened in front
of you with the Clippers come back from
31 down well I mean doc gave a very
flattering unflattering comment that
makes sense about these Clippers man he
called them the roaches so they just
don't die man
you can handle them you could SWAT them
you can step on them and they find a way
to survive a lot of people probably
don't know the Clippers story is there's
been like three games in which they have
over overcame deficits of 20-plus and a
regular season two of which we're over
25 or 25 or over so I mean the Warriors
got to know it you can't just rest you
can't just count them out or think that
they're going to give up this is like
you know a junkyard dog mentality that
they have nobody believes in them nobody
thinks they could win there's no
all-stars there's no superstars although
we should probably start considering Lou
Williams a superstar but they just they
just keep fighting and that has been
their mentality and come back from that
I mean it has to be very very
embarrassing for the Warriors I mean
probably was so embarrassing that it
kind of overshadowed for the moment what
happened with cousins it was a very
quiet locker room a couple guys and
didn't speak and and in this playoff you
can't play games like that because you
know as you saw injuries can happen and
they basically also just lost about
three potential days of rest had they
had swept the Clippers Marc Spears from
the undefeated right here on the Rich
Eisen show and when you meant
the Clippers as roaches it's not just
coming back from deficits within games
it's also Tobias Harris getting traded
away and everybody thinking that's the
end we had doc on the show about ten
days ago then even he admitted that it
was a tough sell within the locker room
to say yeah well let's just keep going
Harris goes to the Sixers so everything
that we're seeing here from from these
comebacks throughout the season last
night Tobias Harris going team is still
in the playoffs right now does this
position the Clippers any better what
happened last night for July first do
you think mark
I mean lawyers when the next three games
will probably forget about it I read I
think it as a 15 minutes of fame it it's
a good story if they win on Thursday or
went on Sunday and which is hey they
could but I with their salary situation
it ain't those guys you know with all
due respect if they're looking towards
to lead their future into trying to
compete for a title it's a guy like
Kevin Durant or a Kawhi Leonard or a
Kyrie Irving that they're really looking
at so I don't know if this impresses a
free agent other to say that you know
the Clippers as the organization are
going in the right direction have a
solid foundation has the owner that
cares and will spend money if somebody
told me before Blake Griffin and Chris
Paul and DeAndre Jordan got all those
masseuses and all the nice stuff now
everybody gets everything so there's a
lot more money being spent in the Obama
regime than the previous regime and a
lot more to be excited about what
Clippers basketball than in the past
Marc Spears in the Honda inside a report
let's get to your piece in the few
minutes we have left with each other
here on the undefeated entitled Kevin
Durant yo just watched the game
you spoke to Durant do you think he has
made a decision on July 1 right now he's
playing basketball knowing he's going to
a certain team if not the next mark no
no and we talked in detail about it I
think he believed it was kind of a
idiotic to have one right now there's
just so many things that could happen
like look what happened to the Lakers in
draft lotteries coming up on May 14th
let's see who gets ayan um let's see how
the Warriors finish I mean if the
Warriors were to three-peat I can
envision stuff being in a room looking
at Durant saying come on man you don't
want to try that for Pete you don't want
to try to for Pete and in a new arena
like just give me another year man let's
just go here to you it's like I could
see that conversation taking place
walking away from a potential for people
it would probably be a very very
difficult thing to do so I mean he
actually I had heard from somebody close
to him that he hadn't made a decision
and then his asked indirectly and he's
like no like that wouldn't be a good
business move at the moment wouldn't be
good for my teammates would it be fair
to my teammates and I think you got to
just like let the dust settle to two
months from now which is why you're
saying hey just just let let's watch
watch me play
and obviously Patrick Beverley is making
a tough warm right now but this is
perhaps the best player in the game and
as after all these sad years at the
Warriors fans have been through I still
think they shouldn't get too big for
their britches and not appreciate the
game the journey there trying to get a
third championship and they need to
smell the coffee a little bit and stop
worrying about what's going to happen in
July want well I mean it regards to mark
I mean Durant as you know is very savvy
smart and so many people say that for
his legacy he's got to go somewhere and
do something himself
to me he looks around even if the
Warriors do lose and there is a new
stadium a new arena
and and if I guess he looks around it
how can he leave this situation knowing
that this is his best chance to win
unless there's something going on behind
the scenes that some other roster move
needs to be made that he doesn't want to
play with anybody anymore and you know I
guess where I'm going to with draymond
and what happened earlier on in the
season is is that walk me through what
the land mines here are of Durant to
stay put in Golden State oh I think him
and and dream on happens on okay I don't
think that pushes him out the door guys
get an argument that happens I'm sure
you didn't haven't loved all your
co-workers all to use either what about
the producer in there man
that's our producer right now I'm
staring a hole right through them right
now Marvin oh yeah I know what you're
saying I mean it happened so I think
that's the thing in the past it'll be
hard to walk away I mean they've been
went in the grass is pretty green on
this side right there's a new marina and
there's like the same kind of money
that's courtside at Madison Square
Garden and at Staples is certainly gonna
be a chase when it's just down the
street Silicon Valley and in San
Francisco the most expensive place to
live in the country is killing me right
now
so I mean from a Silicon Valley
standpoint from a financial standpoint I
mean he's been make a balloon off the
court and I think that will even get to
a higher level next year so New York
won't go away and that's why I think
it's just that's one of those really
really tough decisions where I want to
be surprised it went back to the
Hamptons hunker down with rich climbing
and his father and some other close
friends and and kind of look look at it
I don't think it's a simple decision I
mean New York yeah playing in the garden
is cool and perhaps Kyrie could come
with them but they haven't won since 73
and that's a different kind of pressure
la that the clippers or Lakers it's you
know it's it's a big challenge where you
go regardless to where you go so but he
he has a good problem he has people that
want him and want to open up the vault
for him so um I'm sure I really believed
him when he said that he hasn't made it
decision and he's taking this time okay
mark thanks for the time really
appreciate it let's chat throughout the
NBA playoffs I always appreciate your
your information and your conversation
thank you all right brother take care
you got that smart Spears for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app